[Musica]
mi sono sarà sono un'imprenditrice
questa è la mia città e nel 2002 con mio
marito andrea magelli ho deciso di
partire da qui per fare innovazione è la
nostra prima impresa non aveva nulla a
che vedere con il food noi inizialmente
avevamo nella tecnologia nelle location
al marketing e il nostro progetto ci ha
dato l'opportunità di girare il mondo
lavoravamo per il comitato olimpico le
olimpiadi e ogni volta che andavamo in
giro come italiani ci sentivamo dire voi
siete italiani l'italia il paese
dell'arte della bellezza del food del
cibo del buon vivere del design e poi di
nuovo del food poi di nuovo del food e
quindi a un certo punto nel 2005 ci
siamo detti caspita siamo di bologna il
nostro piatto bologni source e gli
spaghetti alla bolognese anche se a noi
bolognesi non piace dire che il nostro
piatto sono gli spaghetti perché ci
piacciono di più le tagliatelle e in
tutto il mondo tutto il mondo dice che
siamo la mecca del cibo forse anche noi
dobbiamo cominciare a pensare a questo
e quindi così nel 2005
decidiamo di entrare in questo settore
il food è un settore magnifico perché
ovviamente è un settore che parla di
cultura
se io penso quando ero bambina la prima
volta che ho avuto a che fare con la
cina forse avevo 5 anni o sei i miei
genitori mi hanno portato al ristorante
cinese quella è la prima immagine di
cina che io ho stampata nella mia mente
magari non era una cina reale però
sicuramente andando lì ho respirato alla
cultura di un altro popolo e poi il cibo
ci nutre il cibo è vita e quindi
sicuramente è una fortuna poter lavorare
in questo settore un settore che tutte
le persone che tocca
diciamo che è un settore che ti ti ti dà
un senso di rispondere di responsabilità
importantissimo perché ogni giorno in
base a come noi coltiviamo in base a
come noi impacchettiamo il nostro cibo
in base agli ingredienti che utilizziamo
per cucinare
ovviamente ogni giorno le nostre scelte
hanno un impatto sul nostro consumatore
ma anche sui nostri figli in base a cosa
gli do da mangiare
io ho un impatto sulla loro salute o un
impatto sulla salute del pianeta perché
se decido di impacchettare il mio
prodotto con un prodotto poco
sostenibile con un packaging poco
sostenibile genero un impatto che è un
impatto negativo
e così diciamo che nel 2013 riceve un
invito dicevo l'invito a partecipare per
la prima volta al g20 dei giovani
imprenditori
quindi prendo il mio aereo vado a mosca
e cominciò a parlare e interagire con
altri imprenditori che vengono da tutto
il mondo e che mi parlano appunto del
loro settore tutti ovviamente connessi
per che partecipava gruppi di lavoro in
cui si parlava di cibo in cui si parlava
di ristorazione di distribuzione di
grande distribuzione di commodity
alimentari che ovviamente ritornava per
me nella testa questo senso di
responsabilità di essere imprenditori in
questo settore dover fare qualcosa
poi ovviamente apri giornali e vedi che
è un terzo del cibo prodotto nel mondo
diventa spazzatura e poi vedi che c'è
gente che muore di fame o che è obesa
solo che due miliardi di persone nel
mondo sono basie e 800 milioni soffrono
la fame e poi pensi che il 70 per cento
del cibo prodotto sono calorie che non
sono calorie sane non è cibo vero e io
non corre il 70 per cento dell'acqua
potabile viene utilizzata in agricoltura
ovviamente quando però sappiamo che fra
qualche anno
noi non avremo più acqua da bere la metà
del mondo non avrà più accesso ad acqua
potabile e il 95 per cento delle aree
rurali sono nei paesi più poveri del 55
per cento della popolazione che a
planare rurale sono nelle paesi più
poveri e poi nel 2050 il 70 per cento
della popolazione del mondo vivrà nelle
grandi città e quindi bisogna andare a
controbilanciare questo rapporto fra
aree rurali e aree urbane e come leafs
fame remo tutti questi abitanti di
questo pianeta se nel 2050
dovremo produrre il 60 per cento in più
questa è una grande domanda e quindi son
tornata a casa bombardata da stimoli e
ispirazioni e con mio marito
ovviamente cominciavamo a dire caspita
ma chi è che sta facendo la food
innovation chi è che si sta occupando di
innovazione perché si siamo di bologna
si siamo la mecca del food la tradizione
tutto quello che vuoi ma l'innovazione
perché qui se si vuole fare un impatto
vero bisogna innovarlo questo settore e
quindi era il 2013 e abbiamo cominciato
a documentarci e il problema è che tutti
i giornali tutti gli articoli che
leggevamo erano articoli che parlavano
di food innovation ma non qua a casa
nostra la mecca del cibo non si parlava
di food innovation e quindi leggi i
giornali e vedi che a san francisco
fanno la carne in laboratorio che a san
francisco google sta rivoluzionando le
mense ed è una delle aziende più grandi
del mondo o che in olanda ci sono
grandissimi innovazioni nel settore che
in cina si sta innovando nel settore sul
tema della food safety ok ma l'italia
non emergeva pre expo stiamo parlando
del 2013 e quindi decidiamo di prendere
i nostri figli e diciamo andiamo in
silicon valley e decidiamo di passare lì
un interessate alcune settimane e di
andare a conoscere questi veri
innovatori del cibo quindi la nostra
mecca diventa san francisco la capitale
dell'innovazione che a quanto pare stava
lavorando anche tanto su innovazione nel
food e in quel contesto ovviamente
cominciamo a connetterci con questo
ecosistema parlare con questi innovatori
e un incontro diventa incontro veramente
di grande impatto di grande
illuminazione posso dire abbiamo
incontrato l'institute for the futures
l'institute for the feature è un centro
che che studia il futuro da oltre 50
anni e questo centro di ricerca a un
team una squadra che si occupa proprio
di innovazione nella filiera
agroalimentare pensare studiare come le
tecnologie
droni sensori nuovi modelli di stampa
applicati al cibo tecnologie nuovi
strumenti di comunicazione avranno un
impatto con la nostra interazione col
cibo e insieme
scopriamo questa mappa di cui noi siamo
diventati facilitatori da dire non solo
fruitori ma abbiamo contribuito in
seguito allo sviluppo di questa mappa e
questa mappa parla dei scissor
disruption quindi quegli elementi che
andranno a rompere alcuni meccanismi a
impattare la nostra filiera
e sono proprio loro che ci danno una
grandissima ispirazione perché perché
loro che studiano il futuro ci dicono
caspita ma perché venite qui e dite che
il vostro paese non è un paese di
innovazione l'italia per noi è un paese
di grandissimi innovatori voi avete
saputo innovare per secoli sempre di
parmigiano reggiano il parmigiano
reggiano è stato inventato nove secoli
fa dei monaci che volevano semplicemente
fare un prodotto a lunghissima
conservazione che si potesse conservare
per anni e così è nato il parmigiano
reggiano ma parliamo anche dei makers
delle start up delle stampe 3d noi qui
parliamo di fab lab ma le cucine delle
nostre nonne erano altro che fab lab
se si va al museo del patrimonio
industriale le prime macchine costruite
sono macchine che sono state costruite
per facilitare la nostra industria
dell'agroalimentare e poi parliamo di
open innovation il primo ricettario è
nato all'epoca dei romani è il primo
libro di ricette nel terzo secolo quella
era open innovation le ricette erano
esperimenti scientifici ben riusciti che
venivano divulgati e si replicavano e
così torniamo in italia
torniamo in italia e incontriamo nel
nostro cammino persone che stavano
pensando al tema dell'innovazione sempre
l'agroalimentare ma da punti di vista
diversi e incontriamo nel nostro cammino
matteo vignoli che oggi è diventato il
direttore del nostro food innovation
programme e che sta
ma pensando a come aiutare il mondo
dell'impresa dal punto di vista
accademico dal punto di vista
universitario cercando di insegnare
nuovi processi di innovazione e poi
abbiamo incontrato alessandro pirani che
stava lavorando nel mondo delle
istituzioni per capire come fare nuove
politiche nel nostro settore e poi
antonio perdichizzi che stava creando
acceleratori d'impresa lavorando con le
start up e quindi a quel punto abbiamo
deciso di dare vita a feature food
feature food oggi è un mondo un
ecosistema che connette talenti connette
imprese e soprattutto comunità vuole
impattare le comunità quest'oggi è il
nostro nostro grande ecosistema che come
vedete ha un grande cuore di comunità ma
che parte dall educazione e arriva
all'innovazione e il nostro progetto
principale si chiama food innovation
programme che un master che è arrivato
alla sua terza edizione
cosa facciamo con questo master ogni
anno selezioniamo talenti che vengono da
tutto il mondo nel nostro paese per
studiare l'innovazione nel food ed è
vero vengono sono ragazzi incredibili e
riconoscono in noi questo grande
knowledge e soprattutto vedono nella
nostra terra un crocevia di informazioni
contenuti conoscenza scienza di
grandissima ricchezza
il primo anno la prima edizione del
nostro master avevamo la grandissima
fortuna di avere expo in italia
grandissima fortuna perché il mondo era
tutto qui tutto il mondo era qui e
parlava di questi temi stimolava si
incontrava è stato travolgente
ovviamente alla seconda edizione ci
mancava questo expo e abbiamo deciso di
farlo noi abbiamo deciso di prendere i
nostri ragazzi e partire da bologna e
andare a conoscere chi stava facendo la
vera food innovation andare a incontrare
i foo di rose andare a incontrare quei
fu di rose che ogni giorno fanno
innovazione sul campo fanno innovazione
sul campo come magari o fu di rosa è una
maestra ho mai
come steven rizzo che sta lavorando ha
cominciato a lavorare con michelle obama
e ora sta creando impatti incredibili in
tutto il sistema educativo americano o
come michael baker che all'interno di
google ha rivoluzionato e l'inter e
cucine o come il professor mark post che
a maastricht sta creando il famoso
hamburger da un milione di dollari in
laboratorio e tutti questi personaggi
nella loro vita quotidiana che siano
attivisti che siano maestri professori
scienziati stanno generando un impatto e
quindi i nostri ragazzi cosa hanno fatto
durante questi 60 giorni sono partiti
con noi da bologna siamo andati a mastri
che ad amsterdam poi harlem haiti poi a
new york poi san francisco a seul a
kyoto a singapore jean rai a tel aviv a
londra e in ogni tappa hanno raccolto
interviste incontrato innovatori
incontrato start up incontrato
imprenditori raccolto materiale e ognuno
di questi ragazzi aveva un filone di
ricerca specifico il futuro delle mense
scolastiche lo spreco alimentare anche
alcune tematiche di interesse
diciamo che poteva essere di interesse
per la comunità
quindi lo sviluppo della dieta
mediterranea nel mondo e tutti questi
ragazzi sono tornati ovviamente e sono
diventati essi stessi un canale di
trasmissione culturale queste per
esempio era alcune alcune delle immagini
del nostro food da ieri perché in ogni
tappa
noi andavamo a sperimentare quelli che
erano i rituali locali e questo è uno
dei nostri studenti
lui è un ragazzo egiziano ragazzo
egiziano che è una celebrity chef nel
suo paese e mentre eravamo in tour
un giorno ci ha fatto vedere un video e
il telegiornale locale aveva parlato
della nostra missione e aveva parlato di
quello che lui stava facendo in missione
dicendo che questa questo ragazzo
appunto stava ispirando le nuove
generazioni egiziane e tanto è vero che
ora abbiamo un audience araba importante
e lì mi sono resa conto di quanto ognuno
di questi ragazzi
i ragazzi che partecipano alle nostre
summer school le tre edizioni di food
innovation programme i laboratori che
facciamo quei bambini oi ragazzi con i
quali abbiamo lavorato durante
quest'anno provenienti dai licei
italiani e ognuno di questi ragazzi
diventa un potenziale che rende il
nostro impatto esponenziale e così
torniamo alla nostra food valley
torniamo alla nostra fu tale che una
città dove qualcuno avuto il coraggio di
immaginare che si possa aprire un grande
parco tematico qui a bologna che metterà
in mostra le grandi le biodiversità
italiane ma anche i nostri grandi tesori
e che aprirà le porte a migliaia di
visitatori fra poco fra tre settimane
e così qui in questa stessa città anche
noi abbiamo pensato che se vogliamo
avere delle innovazioni che si
trasformeranno in tradizioni domani
dobbiamo per forza oggi facilitare
questa innovazione perché non ci sono
tradizioni se non si investe oggi in
innovazione e quindi vengo ancora più
qui parlando di qui pensando a questa
piazza piazza verdi e voglio pensare al
cibo anche come strumento di
rigenerazione e il caso vuole che
pensando a quanto si può fare attraverso
il food
abbiamo pensato di dare una casa questo
food innovation programme quindi fra
poche settimane tra tre settimane aprirà
in piazza verdi
la nuova scuderia quella che è stata la
mensa universitaria per decine di anni
che continuerà a sfamare studenti ma
continuerà specialmente ad alimentarli
perché all'interno di quella che era la
vecchia scuderia verrà aperto un grande
food lab un foodlab che noi vediamo come
un laboratorio sperimentale che
accoglierà ragazzi da tutto il mondo che
è stato progettato da ragazzi che prima
vivevano quello spazio e che oggi
l'hanno pensato come un luogo di scambio
e coprogettazione ci saranno stampanti
3d per il food un laboratorio sulla
sperimentazione nell'ambito della
fermentazione pensando al cibo come cura
e un laboratorio sull'urban farming un
altro su come valorizzare lo spreco
alimentare quindi sarà uno spazio che
vuole continuare ad alimentare lo
stimolo dell'innovazione in questa
filiera e far diventare la nostra città
non solo la città del cibo buono del
buon vivere ma anche una città dove si
deve venire a studiare l'innovazione
nella nostra filiera e con questo voglio
lasciarvi con un ultimo pensiero che è
una cosa che ritorna sempre nelle nostre
teste ovvero che ogni volta che noi ci
sediamo attorno a un tavolo
noi stiamo gustandoci il passato stiamo
sperimentando il presente ma in realtà
stiamo alimentando il nostro futuro
grazie
[Applauso]